[Applause]
places in this studio you all know our
guest she is the iconic Meredith gray on
the longest running medical drama in
[Applause]
fun fact did we all know that she can
eat an entire watermelon by I hope I'd
like to see that
um please welcome I can't believe she's
here Ellen Pompeo
oh my God
it's so beautiful
and wait you can't eat a whole
watermelon by yourself I've never tried
but let's throw down together let's do
it
um okay you're you've announced that
you're leaving Gray's it's been a
century
it's the longest running show how do you
feel is was it was it are you ready is
it time do you have a next game plan are
you ready to not know what is what is it
feel super happy really
but listen the show has been incredible
to me and and I love I've loved
a lot of the experience listen it's just
I gotta you know I gotta mix it up a
little bit I'm 53 my brain is like
scrambled eggs God you're hot I have to
thank you I gotta do some news I gotta
do something new or I'm gonna literally
turn into like you know you can't choose
a New York Times crossword puzzle every
single day I mean 19 years is like more
that's longer than people keep their
kids in their house like people keep
their kids in their house until they're
18 and then they send them off to
college
so this is like me like going away to
college kind of so what do you want to
do next I I have a lot that I'm doing
um I have three kids
and
um so I take care of them and it's
really important for me to be around for
them and be more present for them I'm
going to do a limited series for Hulu
um in the spring which is a very cool
like kind of crazy true story
um I started I'm excited about that
better better remedy which we're going
to talk about now
um Switching gears a little bit your
level of sticking up for women
you really send me into a how can I be a
stronger more convicted woman because
you have changed the industry for women
with demanding
equal pay
how were you how did you find the
bravery and the strength for yourself or
anyone else to do that because you
change the industry putting up with a
lot of crap
and just being tired of it it's not like
I was born this way it's not well I mean
I am from Boston so I do I think I have
yeah
yeah but I think that Hollywood and a
lot of workplaces
are not necessarily the culture is not
necessarily to empower women or build a
supper make us feel confident secure or
strong
so we don't
and then
by the grace of God you get maybe tired
of putting up with certain things do you
get to a place where you have nothing to
lose I'm sure that's definitely part of
it great point you risked it all and my
gut instinct tells me that because what
you did was so helpful for other people
that it was bigger you made this risk so
personal but you made it bigger than you
and that's why everybody rallied around
you you stayed on that show you got paid
more you changed the game for other
women you became more successful more
respected and in a way you made your
publicist job easier because you won the
battle
and I want to thank you
for showing all women that they can and
should take that risk and maybe it's
doing it for the right reasons
and in the right way but man you handled
an epic sweeping change that I am so in
awe of
thank you
so so many people not in my inner circle
reached out to me and said this is
amazing I mean I icons
the people directly around me
quiet as a mouse on set that day quiet
you could have heard a pin drop so when
your life does change when you are
courageous and fearless and speak out
don't expect everybody to stand up and
cheer for you because they don't
that is a good lesson and I thought that
was really interesting in A Life Lesson
and I've never forgot it
I have always been so enamored with
strong people okay pivoting is it true
that you met your husband in a grocery
store yes how did you meet what happened
what was the encounter so I was with my
mutual friend and they knew each other
but it wasn't like love at first sight
or anything see this is the thing now
okay it's not something romance that
happened over like crackers and cheese
and the aisle and we were like oh my God
you're the one no no no no no wasn't
like that at all so what was it like
just like hey how you doing nice to see
you yeah I gotta go and I walked out and
my friend stayed and talked to him then
we sort of he called me a bunch of times
and I wouldn't call him back and and
then he said you know you're rude you
won't call me back and I said well
because I'm not trying to go on a date
with you and he said who's trying to go
on a date with you I don't even know you
and so we had a fight first and then you
know that's kind of always the way to my
heart is like pissed me off and I'm all
yours
[Applause]
[Music]